so we begin this new Zar with the latest
attempt to resolve the political crisis
in Niger defense Chiefs from the West
African block ecowas they're meeting in
Ghana to discuss the military
intervention since the coup in Niger
last month military leaders have ignored
calls to reinstate the deposed president
Muhammad bazum and are planning to
charge him with treason they've also
appointed a new prime minister and
interim government their Affairs a
military intervention could destabilize
the region so those defense ministers
just arriving in Accra and the meeting
due to get underway shortly Let's cross
now to Charles Stratford who joins us
live
from Accra so Charles tell us a little
bit more about what we're expecting from
this meeting
we're expecting a lot of the focus of
these two-day discussions which we
understand the majority of which will be
a closed door not available to the Press
a lot of the focus is going to be on
this so-called stand by force that was
announced in the last ecowas meeting
last week in Abuja we have very few
details on exactly what that force would
look like but as I say it's a last
resort we also know that there are still
ongoing efforts to try and find some
sort of political and peaceful
diplomatic solution to this crisis to
discuss the crisis in Greater detail I'm
joined by Adama gay
who a dumber gay who is the former
director of communications for Echo ice
thanks for joining us here this morning
sir on Al Jazeera perhaps you could tell
us about some of the concerns with
respect to the lack of unity amongst
ecos countries as they try and deal with
the crisis in Niger
this was expected to happen because the
decision was Hasty and it was the
extreme decision that the organization
should have taken at the last minute
after using the other path diplomatic
past dialogue and other way of ensuring
that at least a conversation can happen
with the coup makers they didn't do that
so going to war as they pretend to do
something that create
I've got a
so we just lost our connection with
Charles uh signals a little bit sketchy
have to say just to recap her we got the
ecowas defense ministers meeting in
Accra in Ghana to discuss possible
military intervention this meeting was
scheduled for Saturday
inaccurable postponed as ecowas
continued to negotiate with military
government in the Army
um the heads of state of Icarus convened
in the Nigerian Capital Buju last
Thursday and now we have this defense
Melissa's meeting to see what is going
to happen next well
the big concern
in this is that any military
intervention by ecowas
could cause problems and threaten
security cooperation in the region West
African nations involved in a shared
battle against armed groups linked to
isil and Al-Qaeda which operate of
course in the Sahar Charles Stratford
sent this report from the Ghana Burkina
Faso border where authorities say
they're struggling to protect the area
there's an uneasy calm along this
isolated border
people walk back and forth across an
invisible line only widely spaced Stone
markers demarcate where Ghana and
Burkina Faso meet
village life seems normal on the surface
but people here are afraid because armed
groups like isil and Al-Qaeda have
killed and destroyed Villages just a few
kilometers away
there has been fighting on the other
side of the hills people from Burkina
Faso fled into our village then went to
a refugee camp we are very afraid that
the fighting may come here
villagers say border patrols pass by
from time to time but Ghana says it's
struggling to find the resources to
police this area
and events in The Wider region could
make things even worse
bikini Faso says any military
intervention by the West African
Regional block ecowas against two
leaders in Niger would be a declaration
of war on them too which could threaten
the security of thousands of ghanaians
living along this border
you really get a sense of just how
exposed this border is the houses behind
me are in Burkina Faso now the Ghanaian
authorities have praised the military
leadership in Burkina Faso saying that
they're doing a good job
in preventing attacks inside Ghana they
say that vital security cooperation
including the sharing of military
intelligence could well be jeopardized
if ecowas was to launch a military
intervention against coup leaders inside
Niger
Northern Ghanaian officials say they
need more resources and working with
Burkina faso's military Junta in their
shared fight against armed groups must
not stop
the issue like this you cannot do it
alone and we are doing it with our
neighbors we're sharing information
working with environment Partners
sometimes you have the same plan have in
Burkina Faso and half in Ghana and
therefore the Chiefs are also helping us
uh with some of these informations
the U.N expressed concern over reports
Ghana was forcibly deporting refugees
who had fled the armed groups in Burkina
Faso but Ghana denies the claim
highlighting similar problems faced in
countries like Iraq where effective
screening of people for being members of
armed groups is a huge challenge
we just received them we screen them
what is your name where are you coming
from that is all what we can do we
cannot dig further to find out who the
person is and that is a great fear
cattle herders roam free with their
livestock across this Borderland as they
have done for millennia
Rural Life Goes calmly on but fear hangs
heavy among people living at the foot of
these Hills John Stratford Al Jazeera on
the Ghana Burkina Faso border
so many many Regional implications
across all of this and that's what's
going to be discussed right here in
Accra you're looking at the the scene
where defense Chiefs from West the West
African block ecowas a meeting uh to
discuss a possible military intervention
since the Tunisia last month's military
leaders have ignored calls to reinstate
the deposed president Mohamed bazoom and
they're planning to charge them with
trees and now these defense ministers
are trying to find some sort of
resolution potentially with military
intervention of some kind let's try and
reconnect with Charles who joins us from
that meeting in Accra Charles it's a
little bit sketchy but we'll give it a
go just tell us more about what's
happening
incredible
well yeah I'd like to get a a
perspective here from our guest that I'm
a gay who as I say was the former
Communications chief for ecowas with
respect to lack of unity amongst ecowas
States sir can you tell us what kind of
impact that is having on on this region
in trying to deal with this crisis it
has a great impact negatively on fixing
this crisis the way the echoas as an
institution wanted to fix it through
military means as they have stated
because there is not unity in the group
whether to go to war or not and this
started with the really the flat barrier
of democracy in West Africa Cape Verde
which is a small island but known for
democracy said no to military
intervention Additionally you have
across the continent many states and
many people the ordinary citizenry in
Africa say no to military intervention
they have the feeling that this is wage
on on behalf of France for a new
Colonial proxy war and within ecowas
itself also you have really the negative
View for the user first from countries
like Niger Mali Burkina Faso Guinea
Conakry military forces that are willing
to go to war against those within ecowas
according for military intervention to
house the current president there that
is led by the junta abdrama chani
would it be safe to say then that a lot
of the regional countries themselves are
looking potentially then at political
unrest inside their borders
because of the opposition amongst
opposition parties opposition groups
Civil Society to any kind of military
intervention
absolutely if they
would work they
formed this region into a bold fire
another Libya we have known what
happened in other places in the world
where there were military intervention
in 2003 in Iraq in 2001 in Afghanistan
America intervened could not fix it but
created a mess behind its forcep same
thing happened in Libya when NATO
intervened there in the case of West
Africa we are here in Burma Camp
military headquarters of the army of
Ghana but you can clearly see that they
don't have the capacity to go to war not
neither logistically nor the result not
the support of the people even the
parliament they have not been consulted
and when they have been consulted there
have been a rejection of military use so
truly
the way Echo was wanted to go from the
beginning should have been less
war-mongering more diplomatic at least
to give themselves a room in order to
make sure that if diplomacy fails then
they can use the stick but they began by
threatening to use the stick and now
they are facing with a safe facing
situation they have to back trap because
they cannot go to war they don't have
the means in if ever any outside
countries like France give them the
military logistic to send their troops
there they will appear as a new Colonial
Force operating on the interest of
France America and other countries are
progressively seeing that this is a real
problem
really highlighting there the the
problems in dealing with this crisis
that is facing this region thank you
very much sir for your perspective on
that and obviously we'll be bringing you
updates as this two-day meeting
continues back to you in Doha all right
Charles yes speak to you later thanks
very much
well as Charles mentioned that's
concerned about stability in New Jersey
neighbors uh the US it says it's worried
about the deteriorating security
situation in Mali Mike Hanna is in
Washington DC and has the latest
the U.S state department has issued a
statement expressing its concern about
the worsening violence in Mali at points
in particular to the attacks on U.N
peacekeepers who are busy withdrawing
from that country following an order by
the military government now that
military government took over power in a
coup a few years ago and since then
they've basically turned against former
Western Partners like France and the US
and have moved towards Russian black
groups like The Wagner groups only a
month ago the U.S state Department
issued sanctions against some of the
Mali governments members because of
their links with that Wagner group now
to the US already experiencing The
Fallout of a similar coup in Niger
having seen one in the neighboring
bikini Faso and of course neighboring
Mali there's great concern about any
instability in that region given that
Nisha was the US's last standing Ally
and until that coup happened recently so
for the US this a major threat to
National Security uh not least the loose
of a loss of its strategic allies in the
region but also the rise in armed
militants setities as this chaos
increases forces such as isil forces
linked to Al-Qaeda gaining greater
mobility and this is something that the
U.S sees as a threat not only to the
regions but also to the US itself
Washington